possecloud is an online platform where
you can easily do and share data work
with just a few clicks we recently added
a new feature called Data connections
which lets you securely store database
credentials and share them across data
projects and among your collaborators
in this tutorial we will demonstrate how
to achieve this by using a publicly
available postgres database let's get
started
the first thing we're going to do is
create a new space you can find this in
the upper left hand nav bar
let's go ahead and create a new space
calling it RNA project
this will create a new space for us to
do work and invite others to collaborate
you can start a new project but before
we do that let's go to data
this is where you're going to add your
new data connection
click on ADD connection
and we're going to make a new connection
name
let's type in RNA Central
which is going to be a postgres database
these credentials are publicly available
and linked to in the description
our user is going to be reader
I'll paste in the password which you can
find online
and the server
finally we're going to go ahead and put
in our port number
and our database name
once we do this we're going to click on
OK
the database connection is going to be
stored and saved
and we're going to be able to use this
in projects so let's go back to content
and now let's create a new
rstudio IDE project from the drop down
while the project is loading let's
rename it
RNA analysis
once posit cloud is done spinning up
your individualized IDE
we're going to be able to access that
database connection that we just defined
so if you look in the upper right hand
of the IDE
and move to the connections tab
we're going to start a new connection
and there it is the database connection
we just saved RNA Central
clicking on this is going to show you a
code snippet which includes all of the
information including the encrypted
password
let's use a new R script
to connect to
and analyze the data
the first thing this is going to do is
load in a necessary package and while
it's doing that let's name the r script
RNA Explorer
from here we can then load the library
that we need
and the DBI library and create our first
connection
the connection has been made and you can
see in the connections tab all of the
schemas available for this database
connection
before we make our first query let's
bring in two libraries
D plier and DB plier
now neither of these have been installed
yet
but the IDE will remind me of this and
we can install right away
once these packages are ready we're
going to hit go ahead and make a query
and we can do this by using the con
variable that has stored the connection
that is still live
let's go ahead and create a new variable
name results
from here
we're going to call the connection
and then bring in the specific schema
name and table that we're interested in
for now
we're just going to go ahead and get the
top 200 results within this table
when I run this
we went to the database we got all the
information in the top 200 rows and now
we can see this in the environment we
have both our connection still
and results data frame which has 200
observations
if we take a quick peek
we can see the type of information that
is stored
and there seems to be an integer
variable length
for each of the observations
we can quickly turn this into a
histogram
to see what we're working with
some observations are in the 0 to 500
range
while many are up around 1200 or above
the best part is if you create a new
project you'll be able to access the
same database connection
and if you change the information from
your connection it'll automatically
update in new and existing projects once
it's relaunched
I hope you enjoyed learning about the
new data connections feature in posit
cloud
you can visit posit.cloud to create a
free account connect to your databases
and begin exploring